with a knocked off Philadelphia at home
capella had 30 and 14 boards against the
Sixers Harden from the wings outlet but
nap
Collins up top to Hunter the tray comes
off the screen moves in put something
the floater and hits it cam read us what
did you see out there and to get that
feedback during the timeout and then
coach did some Corrections and hopefully
we will see more positivity from our
side as the beer goes with the dumping
of the feet the active hands that we'd
like to see that's that's a good good
recovery there he was able to get his
hands in there just in the nick of time
to knock the ball away
harden hit that three and Cam's face
then watch what happens as they went
down the floor that's not all them off
and capela the rebound nice Drive just
shot up a little strong step back for
hard
I'm telling you him he's he had that
explosion off the bench he's been very
good James
Euro steps his way into a layup at a
20-point first quarter particularly from
deep James to the basket and he's got 22
down low and let those guards go
one-on-one against the smaller guys tray
back in scoop to the hoop is good that's
eight points for Trey 14 points for
Clint capela that's a good block there
by Harden he leaks out ahead of the pack
to lay it in 25 for harden good no-call
goon 1 James horn Trey steps back for
three and buries it couple of threes
here at the last few minutes and he got
a look there on that three so that's a
pretty routine shot for him beautiful
one-on-one where the young man just
knows how to get a shot when you go to
work out Eric Gordon when nice little
easy crossover he does takes a one-two
step use the glass
pretty easy he's had 23 in the game this
year seven times this year he's gone
over the 20 mark in rebounds pray young
off the boy after they have the big lead
and start to take tough shots and it
came back to Harlan here's Hart good
this time
if you want to kick down fourth-quarter
state Barbarita tray for 3/3 personal
when trade is taking what he wants on
the defensive end help doesn't come too
late and is a little too late for I
thought he had something going with LEM
on the roll pardon now steps through
lays it in there's no defense for that
jockbox at 12 tre will cry stops block
got it back goes up and scores four
point ballgame